Speaker 1: One of the building stories that we
are continuing to follow is the pivot, or at
least the potential pivot that specifically Fox
News is setting up on the Republican Party and on
the 2024 presidential election. And that pivot is
as follows If Trump is the Republican nominee in
2024, Fox News wants access to him. Fox News wants
to be in the good graces of the administration.
Period. But Fox probably prefers that it
not be Donald Trump who is the nominee.
And there's a bunch of different reasons
why we could imagine that's the case.
One would be that Rupert Murdoch, the patriarch
of Fox News and News Corp., doesn't really like
Trump. That's one possibility. Second is that
Trump is divisive among the right, and that's
not particularly good for Fox News because you
start to have contingents of the right that
like the coverage Fox News is doing and those that
don't. And it's just unnecessarily controversial.
So Fox News is setting itself up with a sort of
escape hatch in case Trump's the nominee. They
want to be able to get back on the Trump train.
But they do seem, at least in this early stage,
sort of to be taking a step toward somebody like
Ron DeSantis or somebody else. The new reports are
that Trump is absolutely furious that Fox News is
ignoring him and giving so much attention to other
potential candidates, according to a report.
Trump hasn't appeared on Fox News in 100 days,
according to the New York Times. He'd rather have
negative coverage than to be ignored altogether.
Trump has reportedly complained to aides
that Sean HANNITY, a longtime friend, is
also overlooking him. Trump is not happy. Instead
of broadcasting a July 22 Trump rally in Arizona,
Fox News aired a Laura Ingraham interview with
Ron DeSantis. A live broadcast of Trump's events
with the conservative event with conservatives
in Washington earlier this week. Was ignored by
Fox for a live speech by Mike Pence, according
to the Times, which cited two people who have
spoken to Trump. Trump is angrier about being
ignored than he would be if Fox were to cover him
negatively. Trump has complained to Sean HANNITY,
as I mentioned, according to several people close
to the Fox Corporation, which Rupert Murdoch owns.
The moves to exclude Trump are not a coincidence.
As Business Insider previously reported, Fox
News is inching towards a post-Trump era.
Trump and Fox News had a falling out when the
network called Arizona for Biden in 2020. Fox
defended the call. Trump protested it. Trump then
moved towards appearing on Newsmax and the One
America News Network. Since then, Insider reported
that a roster of Fox hosts and contributors
have issued stern critiques of Trump and
support for other potential Republican nominees.
In a recent opinion piece by Fox News contributor
Liz Peek, DeSantis was touted as a cure for
an ailing America. Now, there's one thing
that's absolutely true Ron DeSantis would be
a much more effective and probably to the
Republican Party unifying figure than Trump.
DeSantis His politics are not that different than
Trump's. But DeSantis, his personality is less
comically outrageous than Donald Trump's and would
probably not anger as many Republicans as Donald
Trump did. And every report that we're getting,
Business Insider, New York Times reports last week
that we talked about is that it's not by chance
that this is going on. Last week, or maybe it was
the week before I aired a two minute piece that
Fox did with random Republican voters. Right. And
it just so happened that almost every one of those
random Republican voters said, I don't think Trump
should run in 2024. And I really like Ron DeSantis
the way those pieces are produced. Usually you
talk to way more people than you include in the
package, and then you decide what to include.
I'm sure that they came across Republicans
who a bunch of them who said Trump should run.
They chose not to include that. They are starting
to spin a narrative. Remember that Fox News has
not actually abandoned him. Fox News would prefer
someone else and they want to be well positioned
if someone else is the nominee to immediately
be in the good graces of that individual.
But if Trump is the nominee, they want to be able
to get access to him as well. There's a very kind
of strange mix happening right now of cringes,
sucking up to Trump, but also mentioning that
there is lots of Republicans out there. They're
out there in the ether who would prefer somebody
other than Donald Trump. And this shouldn't really
come as a shock because it's a repeat of 2016.
In 2015 into 2016, Fox did not like Donald
Trump. They were supporting other people.
I believe it was Ted Cruz. They were pretty,
pretty positive on until it became clear that
Trump was going to be the nominee. And then all
of a sudden they were tripping all over themselves
to brown nose and to get in Donald Trump's
good graces in which they were for the vast
majority of Trump's presidency. So this is
not a new pattern. But Trump is reportedly
furious. Trump being furious can only lead to
hilarity. And we'll be standing by for that